[Music]
there's no secret that the number one
question for both presidential
candidates has been how do we get people
back to work that has been the big theme
of this campaign well ladies and
gentlemen I'm proud to announce a new
sponsor of ours thinks they have a very
interesting solution 12.5 million people
are out of work another eight hundred
forty-four thousand are so discouraged
they're not even looking that's why I
formed Robicheaux partners the first
simulated work environment for the
unemployed it's so good to be back to
work
this guys will be hard to catch mr.
Robicheau I'm on a deadline
those are blank pieces of paper it
doesn't matter well he's busy well I
don't want to talk about the third
quarter by together followings not even
plugged in it's not real work what it
feels like
Oh Manny second floor men's room sink
Amana mr. our he's actually a rumor show
employee as well all the trappings of
the job you used to have like big
important meters of cells all the market
shares quarterly and with all the
business and awkward staff birthday
parties
you did it your old job you can do here
let's see what my vice president's up to
only 270 $9.99 a month you get to feel
like you have a job and what's better
you get to save you have a job
hi babe it's gonna be a late one totally
swamped here
no problem money in your monthly fee
free transportation to your local
Robicheaux office doctor you'll excuse
me I have work to do
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]